so here we have a sample of cobalt now
I've got lots and lots of different
samples of cobalt in my draw so this is
cobalt sponge cobalt is in many ways
similar to iron it can form magnets so
that cobalt has been generated from a
solution and it's been made in very very
finely dispersed or as a very large
surface area it's very good for doing
catalytic reactions the magnets that you
use in color televisions for the
loudspeakers contain cobalt you need to
use cobalt in the magnets in the color
television or the old sort of color
television not the ones with LCD screens
because the magnetic field from larger
magnets could affect the electron guns
and so spoil the colors so you need a
very small magnet on your loudspeaker or
the colors all go funny
cobalt sponge absorbs lots and lots of
gas were perhaps hydrogenation many
years ago in the 1970s when there was a
civil war in Africa in the region
Katanga where cobalt is mined there was
a shortage of cobalt and the production
of color television stopped for some
considerable time until the production
restarted so you can see it flows in the
bottle so I have another sample of
cobalt and that's simply a foil so again
it's a very nice malleable tin for
tintype foil very very good structures